he's the world number one tennis player
and has won nine of his 20 major titles
at the australian open this year he gets
to defend his title after announcing on
instagram that he was exempt from the
country's vaccination rules and was
granted permission to travel to
melbourne
obviously the announcement uh by novak
that uh he has been granted a medical
exemption and um and that exemption
affords him the opportunity to come into
australia coming to victoria and compete
at the australian open so he's currently
on on a flight on his way here and and
gets here sometime today the decision
has triggered widespread anger in a
country that's had to deal with some of
the toughest covert restrictions on
travel both interstate and overseas
and from those in a city that have
endured the world's longest cumulative
lockdown to contain the pandemic i think
it's disgusting i don't know how you can
get a medical exemption when you play
that when you're that fit and you play
and you're number one in the world i
think it's a disgrace we've all done the
right thing we've all gone out and got
our our jabs and our boosters and
um we have someone that's come from
overseas and all of a sudden he's he's
been exempt and can play and i think
it's an absolute disgrace and i won't be
watching it
all players and tournament staff must be
vaccinated to have an exemption to take
part in the australian open that starts
on january 17.
last year the world number one tennis
player said he was personally opposed
and wouldn't want to be forced by
someone to take a vaccine in order to
travel
the australian open ceo and the
government in the state of victoria have
denied djokovic got special treatment
but say it's up to the tennis player to
reveal his medical condition it's very
clear on what
conditions you would receive an
exemption on and to briefly quickly
summarize those one of them is obviously
having an adverse response to any kind
of vaccine and having something like an
anaphylactic response another one is if
you've just had major surgery and may or
may not be suffering from myocarditis
and another one is your recovered case
the prime minister was quick to deflect
any criticism the victorian government
have made their decision on that and so
i'd have to refer to the victorian
government about their reasons for doing
so something omicron has now reached
every state in australia more than 90 of
people aged over 16 have had two doses
of the vaccine
even so the number of daily infections
in most states is reaching record levels
some testing centers have been forced to
close to deal with the backlog the
national cabinet led by the prime
minister has now agreed to provide
concessional access to rapid antigen
tests in a bid to ease pressure on a
health system struggling to cope
sarah clark al jazeera queensland
australia